I think Google was asked how many AI
breakthroughs they would reveal
yesterday on stage and they replied yes
because two and a bit years after
Microsoft CEO said he wanted to make
Google dance Google's CEO Zundachai and
resident noble laurate Demesis Arbis
performed a 2-hour breakdance routine
honestly there were enough announcements
to make 10 to 12 separate videos but for
now I will just give you a sense of the
breadth of what they released or said
they would soon release not going going
to lie, it was kind of tempting to make
the entire video a VO3 montage, but no,
it was much more than that. Suffice to
say, every other AI rival on the planet
took a big gulp. So, from the useful to
the entertaining, the impressive to the
meh, here's the gist of the 12 most
interesting to me dance moves. Now, I
have to start obviously with V3 because
adding sound to video was such an
obvious step, but the effect is
remarkable. Generating videos with
built-in dialogue really changes things,
doesn't
it? V2 was already incredible, but
across a thousand prompts, VO3
outperformed V2 and the newly released
Cling 2.0 and of course, OpenAI Sora.
Over 80% of the time, people preferred
V3's output. But before I get to the
obligatory 45 seconds worth of samples,
a quick word on price and availability.
Only the $250 tier, Google AI Ultra will
get access to V3 currently. Oh, and
that's only if you are in the US. And
trust me, I have tried to get access,
but so far to no avail. This isn't like
Sora where a quick VPN will do the
trick. With that caveat said, in these
clips, notice both the dialogue that's
generated by V3 and the sound effects.
The sum of the squares of the two
shorter sides is equal to the square of
the longest side.
Our video model. Yeah, it's the best.
Straight up. No cap. You know how we do.
V3 rules. Yeah, the whole damn crew.
But if you thought that yesterday's IO
was just V3 plus a sprinkle of other
bits, then you might well be in for a
surprise because I don't know if you
caught this, but the Gemini 2.5 flash
update was a price shock akin to the
Deepseek R1 bombshell. Think performance
on par with Deepseek R1 at one quarter
of the price. And this is comparable
performance with much more expensive
models. whether we're talking about
general knowledge, tough science
questions, mathematics, or coding. And
I'm not sure if you guys caught this,
but Gemini 2.5 Flash also has native
audio generation, so you can control
what one speaker or multiple speakers
say, their accent, and even instructions
like giggling, sighing, or groaning.
Crisp, sweet, juicy
bite. Red, green, or yellow delight.
Autumn's perfect treat.
This is for 24 languages, by the way,
and the model can switch between
languages in the same output. The next
thing isn't here yet, so take it with a
grain of salt. But Demesis Arbis
described a universal AI assistant. And
this might remind you of something, but
they demoed an agent that could make
calls on your behalf. We've seen that
one before, but this seems real. And
also shop for you. A bit like OpenAI's
operator, but all in one package. Now,
yes, this might seem theoretical, but
live as of yesterday across all of
Android is Gemini Live. Open the Gemini
app, tap the bottom right button, and
you can share what your camera sees in
your phone and have a live conversation
with Gemini. The next thing that caught
my eye isn't a new feature or a new
model, but two statements that Google
CEO made that I found pretty
interesting. First, as you can see, it's
not just that 400 million people are now
using Gemini every month. they're using
it more. So, as compared to this time
last year, there are 50 times the number
of tokens or let's say words being
generated by Gemini AI models. I think
you guys saw this before anyone, but AI
is not a fad. It's not going anywhere.
The next statement, not feature or
model, was a cheeky slap at OpenAI for
their recent struggles with models being
sickantic, flattering the user. You
might not have noticed this reference,
but I think Google was making a pretty
clear statement. Sick convertible
garbage truck again. Anything else? Why
do people keep delivering packages to my
lawn? It's not a package. It's a utility
box. Why is this person following me
wherever I walk? No one's following you.
That's just your shadow. Gemini is
pretty good at telling you when you're
wrong.
The next announcement that will almost
certainly be a video when it's actually
released was of course Gemini 2.5 Pro
Deepth thing. Officially only available
on that $250 tier, but I think I'm going
to be able to get access in the next
couple of days. That's of course to run
it on SimpleBench, but we already have
some scores where this deep think mode
outperforms not just Gemini 2.5 Pro
vanilla, but 03 and 04 Mini from OpenAI.
Yes, on coding but also mathematics
quite dramatically and multimodality.
This is the mmu which is about analyzing
charts, graphs and other visuals.
Essentially Google's claim here is that
with deep think you will have access to
the smartest model on the planet. Now of
course we will have to test that and
let's just say that by tomorrow there
might be other contenders. Hint hint.
But Google did give us a slight nod as
to how it performs so well. I listened
to various surrounding interviews and of
course the full 3 hours of video
materials from the IO and they kept
hinting about parallel samples and I was
like hm that sounds familiar. I covered
the bombshell Google paper that talked
about sampling and scaling up inference
time search. This was on a recent
Patreon video. But for those who aren't
going to see that video, it basically
said that scaling up the samples that
you analyze in a modular approach can
beat scaling up the length of chain of
thought. The key author called this yet
another access in which the AI labs can
scale up their compute spend. Onto
something which I think they have
massively overhyped in the past, which
is AI overviews, which is incredibly
untrustworthy. Of course, they focused
on its successes and how it scaled up to
1.5 billion quote users. While I do
wonder how many of those 1.5 billion
users were given erroneous results, they
did announce that in future, I think
from now it will be powered by a custom
2.5 model, probably something akin to
Gemini 2.5 flash light, but either way,
expect accuracy to hopefully improve
quite significantly. I wouldn't normally
feature something like this, but for
something that's going to be used by
billions of people, I think it is
significant. While we're on search, I
have to mention AI mode, which for me is
Google's attempt to be a perplexity
killer. Yes, you can engage in a back
and forth conversation by the summer
apparently is going to be able to book
things for you like an agent, perform
deep researches, and do data analytics.
Now, none of those features might be new
to any of you guys, but it does show
that Google is preparing rapidly for the
days where that classic search bar is
replaced by AI mode. Speaking of Google
Deep Research, that too has seen a
pretty big upgrade. The model behind it
has been upgraded and if you are on the
pro tier, you get the full 2.5 Pro to
power it. And yes, like OpenAI's deep
research, you can now use your own
files. But I think there is something
much cooler about the new Deep Research
because I'm going to be totally honest
with you guys, but I found the original
deep research very verbose. like it
would always generate these 20page
reports, even if I asked for something
quite simple. Indeed, that was the case
when I asked it just now, find out 50
incredible facts about Alpha Evolve, my
previous video. But now, Google deep
research is integrated with their canvas
feature. So, you can instantly turn that
deep research report into an interactive
website, for example, or maybe just a
chart, a table or a podcast using
Notebook LM. So, while it's good to be
comprehensive, I now think most users
will have something that they can use on
a daily basis. Speaking of coding, I'll
quickly throw in Google's Jewels, which
is the rival to OpenAI's codeex
announced just a few hours before. But
with Jules, anyone can sign up and it's
free up to five tasks per day, powered
by 2.5 Pro. Obviously, I'll have to test
it side by side, but Jules can import
your GitHub repo, clone it virtually on
the cloud, verify different changes
actually work, for example. And if you
are new to all of that, Google have
produced a replet rival. This was
featured in the developer session, but
essentially you can not only develop an
app, but also deploy it on Google Cloud
Run. Yes, they are fairly basic apps
that you can create for now, but other
people can essentially see what you've
made and try it out and enjoy it. Let's
though go back to some sweet visuals
with Imagine 4, their latest textto
image model. In their promotional
materials, Google leaned into the finer
details that Imagine 4 can do, as well
as text fidelity. If you see this image
of sheep in a field with knitted yarn, I
tried the exact same prompt in GPT image
one and got this. But rather than just
rely on a sample size of one, they
actually showed us some benchmarks. Now,
it's a busy chart, but Google is
essentially admitting that GPT image 1
still outperforms Imagine 4 on ultra
settings, but takes a lot longer to
generate its images. So for text to
image, it's probably fair to say Google
has caught up to OpenAI and that image
generation model you see in Chat GBT,
but hasn't surpassed OpenAI. But I will
say that if it's speed you're looking
for, look no further than Gemini
Diffusion, the model that no one saw
coming. It's not out yet. I'm on the
wait list, but it is a totally different
way of doing language modeling. I'll
summarize how it works in a second, but
first, how fast does it work? Well, you
can see the prompt and there's the
answer. Google say that the Gemini
diffusion model is five times faster
than their fastest current model. I
mean, you can just pause and think
through the implications of that.
Imagine in the near future an instant
app developed just with a voice prompt.
How can it possibly be that fast? Well,
diffusion models work differently to
auto reggressive or tokenby token
language models. Here's a quick analogy
I came up with. Let me know if you like
it. Almost all language models you are
familiar with work by predicting the
probability of a set of possible next
words in the sequence. The fusion models
can work on the entire output at once.
It's a bit like the difference between
one person rapidly placing Lego blocks
to build up an entire statue. That's
auto reggressive models. With the fusion
models, it's a bit like having a giant
cube of Lego bricks and you're trying to
make that statue. you already have the
cube and 100 like-minded people each
come along and take or add a block from
that cube for a few turns until the
statue is revealed. Going from a block
of noise to a sculpted statue in far
less time. But do you have to sacrifice
performance? Well, the early benchmarks
say probably not. Depends on the domain,
of course, and we'll all have to do
plenty of testing, but the signs look
good. As I mentioned at the start of
this video, this announcement alone,
Gemini diffusion could have been an
entire video and hopefully one day soon
will be. On a much lighter note, of
course, I can't help but mention the new
try it on feature from Google. I'm sure
all of you guys and gals will be using
this almost immediately. But the
interesting bit for me was that Google
made their own bespoke image generator
model just so that you could input a
photo of yourself and try different
fashionable items on before you buy
them. Okay, might not be as crazy
impressive as the other announcements,
but designing a bespoke model for that
is a little bit of a flex. One thing I
thought I would quickly flag up is that
Google announced a synth ID detector.
Now, it's fairly old news that Google
adds a synth ID watermark to its text
and its images and videos. But the synth
ID detector, I think, is worth flagging
up because they're inviting journalists,
academics, and other researchers to be
able to input a certain image or text
and get the answer as to whether Google
thinks it was done by Gemini or indeed
Imagine or V3. So, just be aware that
everything you create with Google isn't
just watermarked, but now there are
third parties who will be able to detect
that watermark. Before we get to
possibly the coolest development, let me
introduce you to the 80,000 Hours job
board. 80,000 Hours are the sponsors of
today's video, and they present an
answer to this question. Yes, there are
so many opportunities in AI and beyond,
but it can be increasingly hard to find
real jobs selected for positive impact,
such as in AI security. The 80,000 hours
job board has literally pages and pages
of great jobs, actual paying jobs. The
link is in the description. You may
remember from previous slots, but they
also have an epic podcast and career
guide. But I'm going to end with the
Gemmaverse, the user created universe of
openweight models. And I'm not even
going to focus on Gemma 3N, which is a
model that can fit onto your phone or
even Medgema with state-of-the-art
performance for medical question
answering. I just thought that SGemma
was so cool. SGMema is a new family of
models trained to translate sign
language to spoken language text but
it's best at American Sign Language in
English and he went on to feature their
work on Dolphin Gemma which I covered in
a previous video. But I must say for
those cynics out there who thought all
the other announcements are bunkham,
you've got to admit that is pretty epic.
A language model for sign language. So
what did you guys think? Overhyped or
the biggest day in AI so far. Now I
probably shouldn't, but I just can't
resist that I'm going to end with some
more VO3 clips. So whatever you made of
the news over the last 24 hours, I hope
you have a wonderful day. We can talk.
No more silence. Yes, we can talk. We
can talk. We can talk. We can talk with
accents. Oh, I think that would be
marvelous. Yes, it is very fun. But yes,
it is very good. Very fun. I can talk.
Yes, we can talk. Yes, we can talk. We
can talk. We can talk. Yes, we can talk.
No. Yes,
we can talk as cartoons. This is
amazing. Imagine all the narrative
possibilities. We can sing talk.
[Music]
Let's talk. So, what are we going to
talk about now? What are we going to
talk about now that we can talk? I have
no idea. What do you want to talk about
now that I can talk? No.
I I don't know if I have something to
say.
We can talk about how magical this is.
is I'm a hallucin.
I want to say something important,
something deep.
The future is still in our hands.
That's cliche dialogue.
Let's not talk.
Welcome to a non-existent car show.
Let's see some opinions. I mean, man,
the acceleration is crazy. You look far,
step on the pedal, and you are there. I
feel safe with him in an SUV, and it
seems to be like the right type of car
for him. I think the range is only um
only going to get better.
Sorry.
We don't want to drive gas cars anymore.
Yeah, no more gas cars.
You can see uh I'm kind of a kind of a
misfit here, but uh don't tell anyone
I've just bought an electric car. I
think it's really great for families and
for little babies with all the safety
features that these SUVs have. But what
you're really seeing is that technology
is going to be very very important in
terms of how we go forward. It was
um great to come to the conference
because my husband loves cars. I think I
have to buy an EV now. I love my muscle
cars,
but I try to stay as healthy as I can so
I can make it to the next car show.